[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
i've got something a little bit
different for you guys and it's not
something that i've done much of on the
channel before and that's a review
but it's not just any review it's the
review for the latest installment of the
fantastic beasts films fantastic beasts
secrets of dumbledore this film has been
a long time coming almost four years to
be exact as crimes of grindelwald the
last film was released in november of
2018 but that isn't even when we were
first introduced to this story and these
characters as the very first film came
out in november of 2016. nearly six
years ago we've been waiting a long time
for this story to continue i digress
today i'm going to be giving you my
honest review of the film including but
not limited to what i expected out of it
what there is to come what was good and
what was bad this review will contain
spoilers and i'd hate to ruin it for
anyone so if you're not okay with that
then come back to this video once you've
seen it but if you have seen it then
stick around and afterwards be sure to
leave a comment with what you thought of
it down below i'll give a score at the
end it's 1am now and i went to the 7 15
pm screening of the film in canada where
i live tonight was the premiere if you
didn't know i'm originally from the uk
but i've lived in canada for a long time
now to kick things off i'd like to first
state that yes i was excited for this
film
a lot of harry potter fans have been put
off the franchise namely through drama
pertaining to the casting of the films
and or the negative impression that the
first two installments left on fans
however i have never been particularly
critical of the fantastic beasts films
that have been released so far and i can
say this with confidence because i'm
always conscious of one thing
they are not the harry potter films if
you go into fantastic beasts any of them
thinking that you're going to get harry
potter pure unadulterated harry potter
then you're going to be bitterly
disappointed and that mindset should be
extended to this most recent installment
this is the harry potter universe but
not exactly harry potter if you want ron
hermione and voldemort and you're unable
to move on that then this isn't for you
however i will say this the fantastic
beast films are slowly bridging that gap
between the two film franchises and with
each subsequent film we seem to be
getting more and more parallels with the
original beloved harry potter franchise
which is a nice touch and no it's not
breaking canon well most of the time
but it is providing us with more and
more information related to the
backstories of some of our favorite
characters and creatures i particularly
enjoy that it's expanding on family
trees as this just makes the wizarding
world feel even bigger i think the
additional connections can largely be
attributed to the inclusion of harry
potter screenwriter steve cloves who
joined for this film and will likely
join for the subsequent films the
opening scene of this film which depicts
an elegant setting in which dumbledore
and grindelwald are sitting across from
each other
drinking tea exudes class
i say this while i'm sat here eating my
third jello cup despite the obvious
tension between the two gentlemen the
encounter appears to be quite civil
surprisingly civil even particularly as
we know what grindelwald is capable of
this is the first time in the fantastic
beast films that we're actually seeing
grindelwald and dumbledore engaging face
to face they must say that it's a breath
of fresh air i mean the whole story is
based around their relationship and
that's because grindelwald is an
unstoppable villain and dumbledore is
the only good guy that's able to bring
him down but what appears to be quite
civil and light-hearted including quips
and how good muggles make tea very
quickly turns rather sinister when
grindelwald says to dumbledore with or
without you i'll burn down their world
this straightaway gives us a sense of
the world that we're being introduced to
a time of tension a time of a potential
wizarding uprising that would
effectively eradicate and or enslave
muggles the theme of racism and
pureblood elitism is thrown right in our
faces before albus has had a chance to
finish his cup of tea while racism and
prejudice have always been a central
theme of the harry potter films
fantastic beasts hasn't been too direct
about it yet which makes grindelwald's
genuine and direct disdain come across
as a bit of an homage to the original
films perhaps skirting around the topic
and distracting us with sweet little
creatures is now finally a thing of the
past if you thought this story was going
to be based around newt famed magic
zoologist as the previous two films
mostly were then you'd be wrong and the
first clue is that newt doesn't appear
in the first scene
yes he appears in scene number two but
clearly the films have made a
substantial shift from nude to albus
this is a shift i'm fond of and it's not
because i don't like newt but there
certainly isn't enough there to make
multiple films newt's cutesy little
adventures certainly warrant some screen
time but the depth of fan favorite
dumbledore will always continue to spark
our curiosity he's the most powerful
wizard in the world he's exceptionally
wise his family is full of drama and he
had a relationship with the most
dangerous dark wizard of all time
newt's got a case full of creatures an
awkward undefined relationship with his
assistant bunty who seems to be obsessed
with him and an even more confusing
relationship with tina goldstein who he
can't seem to just ask out nevertheless
the film certainly does include newt and
our first exposure to his character
comes in scene number two when we see
him in the jungle in queensland china
tending to some kind of new adorable
bambi-looking never-before-seen magical
creature called a chillin right after
the film ended i googled the creature's
name and discovered two things number
one it's pronounced chillin but it's
actually spelt with the q
q-i-l-i-n
number two this creature was actually
inspired by chinese mythology the
chilean is also known as a chinese
unicorn and symbolizes both good luck
and prosperity anyway as it turns out
this creature is a major focal point of
the story perhaps a little bit too much
of a focal point
after being ambushed by grindelwald's
acolytes credence and vinda rosier newt
is incapacitated and the chilean is now
in grindelwald's possession this brings
us to dumbledore and his request of newt
to assemble a motley crew that will be
given the incredibly daunting task of
confusing grindelwald i say confusing
him because grindelwald after
slaughtering the innocent chilean was
able to harness its ability for
precognition this makes grindelwald even
more difficult to deal with so who
better to take on the most dangerous
dark wizard of all time than
newt's brother theseus newt's assistant
bunty newt's muggle baker friend jacob
and the newly introduced ilvermorny
professor eulally hicks who is a welcome
addition i might add tina goldstein who
played a significant role in the
previous two films is suddenly nowhere
to be seen the explanation for which is
that she has taken on a new role as head
of the aura department tina does show up
later on in the film but barely and i'm
not sure there's even much of a point
i'm really not sure what could have
possibly been more important than taking
down the largest imminent threat in the
wizarding world helping the man she
loves and oh i don't know saving her
sister with the general theme of racism
established and intensified by the
setting of 1930s berlin our attention is
quickly brought to what is surprisingly
the main focus of the film an election
this was a bit of a letdown the film was
based in a time of unrest because you
see an election was about to take place
that would instate a new president or
supreme mugwump for the international
confederation of wizards the current
president anton vogel was a secret
supporter of grindelwald which led to
him exonerating grindelwald from his
alleged crimes this meant that
grindelwald could run for president and
this is a big problem because of the
power that the position holds
grindelwald wanted war on muggles and
this would give him every right to wage
war on behalf of the wizarding
population after watching trailers for
the film i thought it was going to go
like this grindelwald would successfully
become president he'd rally witches and
wizards under his cause using his
charisma and he'd continue to grow in
power even as the film came to an end
saving his defeat for later i thought
he'd have started a revolution i thought
he'd have forcibly taken the position of
president
but as it turns out grindelwald played
the politician game and in actual fact
didn't have the enormous devout
unwavering following that i expected him
to have instead of relying on his charm
charisma and immense power he was
instead relying on the chilean when we
arrived at the kingdom of bhutan where
the presidential elections are held
grindelwald had done just one thing to
ensure his victory bewitched the chilean
to choose him for you see whoever the
chilean chooses becomes president was
this movie about rigging an election
grindelwald put way too much faith in
this strategy instead of utilizing his
existing resources like the support of
the existing president he relied on
something that could and eventually did
fail
why well the motley crew assembled by
newt came through in the nick of time
delivering the chilean's twin which was
very much unbewitched the healthy
chilean then chose candidate vicenzia
santos as the new president after first
using dumbledore foreshadowing there and
effectively exposed grindelwald's deceit
losing his patience with credence who
was the first to publicly point his
finger at him grindelwald fired what
appeared to be a killing blow at
credence which was then blocked by
dumbledore
this incited a jewel between the two men
and i found this to be particularly
interesting as it answered the question
of which man is more powerful despite
grindelwald being in possession of the
elder wand dumbledore was able to get
the better of him but did also seemingly
allow him to run off and disappear just
minutes before promising theseus that
he'd find him shortly after
grindelwald's escape the film shifts
focus to the closing scene the wedding
of jacob and queenie who finally after
all they had endured were able to get
married
that's how the film ends
given the film's 2-hour and 23-minute
run time i would have liked to have seen
development beyond the election i don't
know if this is just me but i was hoping
that the election would be a smaller
segment of the film and not the primary
focus i wanted grindelwald to brutally
enforce his power and sway the masses
i wanted a dark and powerful takeover of
the wizarding world and i wanted to see
what would happen after grindelwald's
takeover grindelwald was only in power
for a few minutes so we never really got
a chance to experience how things would
have changed but i suppose there's still
room for that in the films to come
i also would have liked to have seen
more emphasis placed on some of the
other characters who had little
development in this one characters like
eulali hicks music karma and theseus to
name a few even credence despite getting
some screen time and a massive identity
unveiling played a considerably smaller
role than in the previous films my main
negative takeaway is that i wish that
more happened however i do have plenty
of good things to say about the film
here are just a few
first it felt a lot more like harry
potter i know i mentioned earlier that
the fantastic beast films are bridging
the gap to harry potter but this film
certainly did the best job so far
it certainly didn't feel like a
different universe anymore and that's a
big win for me second the film may not
have included everything i wanted but it
did leave the door wide open for more
films which we're supposed to get two
more of i did hear rumors that it was
all going to be over and done with after
this one so i was really glad to leave
the theater knowing that there's going
to be more on the way then the film had
some epic fight sequences we saw albus
dumbledore duel not one but two powerful
wizards and dominate both of them this
only adds to the allure of dumbledore's
enigmatic character
fourth we have a new family member to
add to the dumbledore family tree the
dumbledores are as enigmatic as they
come and the addition of credence
certainly livens things up who's his
mother fifth mass mickelson was an
excellent gaelic grindelwald whatever
your stance may be on the johnny depp
situation maz crushed it sixth we're
really starting to escape the cutesy
feel of the previous fantastic beast
films i love magical creatures and the
films may be named after these creatures
but i need more beyond the novelty of a
cute quirky creature and we're certainly
heading in the right direction
overall i enjoyed the film and i would
venture to say that this was an
improvement over the previous two films
which i also enjoyed currently secrets
of dumbledore is scoring 6.6 on imdb 51
on rotten tomatoes and a brutal 47 on
metacritic these are all lower than the
score i'm going to give it which is a
7.25
however i think the story is set up
beautifully to have two follow-ups which
absolutely smash it and it's encouraging
to see that the films are only getting
better from its reinvigoration of magic
to its beautiful sets and costume design
for a casual observer i think this film
delivered but for us die-hards we still
need just a little bit more should you
watch it absolutely leave a comment down
below with what you thought and if you
have any questions about the film then
leave those in the comments too until
next time remember
do what is right not what is easy
[Music]